a handshake that will infuriate Russia
President Vladimir zielinski hosted the
leader of NATO Yen stoltenberg for a
meeting in Kiev and after more than a
year of War stoltenberg carried a
message that Ukraine can eventually find
a place in the western military Alliance
let me be clear
Ukraine's rightful place is in the
euro-atlantic family
Ukraine's rightful place is in NATO
and over time our support will help you
make this possible
it's not the first time stoltenberg has
said this kind of thing but the
symbolism of him saying it in cave is
powerful the Kremlin was quick to
respond saying that Ukraine shift
towards NATO was one of the reasons why
Russia began what it calls its special
operation in the first place
but for president zielinski it's a
moment of hope
we interpret this visit of the Secretary
General the first of the full-scale war
as a sign that the NATO alliance is
ready to start a new chapter in
relations with Ukraine a chapter of
ambitious decisions
I urge the Secretary General to help
overcome the Restraint of our partners
in supplying some weapons including
long-range weapons modern Aviation
artillery and armor delaying decisions
is time that is lost for peace and this
means the lives of our Warriors
will immediately get is more of this
Russian designed MiG-29 fighter jets
donated by its neighbor and NATO member
Slovakia they may be old stock retired
from use by Slovakia last year but
Ukrainian Pilots are familiar with them
and they can go straight into Service as
Ukraine prepares for its imminent spring
offensive
needs are defensive Russian air attacks
by missiles and drones continue
eight civilians were killed in this
attack on the eastern city of slovance
last week the Ukrainian Air Force
command now admits that it needs more
ammunition for its air defenses